So last week we talked about the need for love when we're engaging in conversation and we want to get out
We want to be loving to other people
But if you or any of your students are all like me
That very concept is
terrifying
The fact that I have to go out not the love part that's not so terrifying
But the part you go out and actually have a conversation is terrifying. I need a plan of attack
I am in some of your students. I'm sure are very introverted very reserved and
I'm not I'm not all that good at the small talk. I'm just sort of having a conversation
In fact, I actively try to avoid small talk. I like to get to the point
So when I'm entering a conversation about
Spiritual things or I want to advance a conversation and get to the gospel so I can get to Jesus because I want them to
Know who Jesus is. I need a plan of attack
But it but I'm sure that many of your students and maybe yourself because I know I get there all the time is
What happens when they ask you a question that you can't answer?
Because what happens is we get into these moments where we say
Somebody asks us a question. We really want to have an answer to come right back and be like, yeah
I've got that answer and I've got that answer because we feel like if we have all of the answers
Then we can somehow convince the other person that what we believe is absolutely right because we've got all the answers to all their questions
Well, nothing could be further from the truth. That's not at all the case and there are gonna be times when we get stumped
And we don't know what to say or the person that we're talking to has a belief system or a view on things that we're just not all
That familiar with you can't know everything about every single person
But there's a really simple strategy that I want you to sort of add in
To talk with your students about is when you're engaged in a conversation
You want to make sure that you are asking questions. That's what this week is all about the idea and the art of asking
Questions questions are so so important. See if we ask good
Questions, then we're gonna get probably good answers and just like any good teacher knows you don't ask yes or no questions
You ask sort of in-depth sort of probing questions
Why kinds of questions to draw out of people the answers that that that you want that you need
Well, the same goes true with our conversations
But this especially works if you have no idea the other person is talking about
Because you can probe a little bit deeper and get them to talk through at the same time
You're you're giving off the idea because you are and you want to be
Extremely interested in what they have to say and that goes back to last week when we talk about love and building relationships
And that sort of thing so there are two specific questions that we can ask somebody if you get stumped
Okay, so the first question is simple. What?
do
you
mean
By that
So this question is used when you're really not sure what all
the person thinks
Person says something that you just not all that clear on
I believe that Jesus is just a good moral teacher
What do you mean by that like you can probably guess what they might mean?
But maybe that's not what all the God just you know doesn't exist because there's too much evil in the world
Well, what do you mean by that and if you're you can what do you mean by that people to death?
It's just you can go over and over and over again
What do you mean by that or some variation of it?
But it's a very simple question that does two things one it digs deeper into the person what they're actually thinking
But it also buys you time
To think about what you want to say a little bit
So it allows them to clarify what they're saying so they can't just make a one-off statement to you
But it also buys you a little bit of time to think through their opinion more more thoroughly and more thoughtfully
the second question is
How do you come to that conclusion or did you come?
Again people make one-off statements all the time
How'd they get there?
So if they again, they said something like you know God can't exist because there's too much evil in the world
Well, how do you come to that conclusion?
There's a much larger explanation that I need for that
And you know at this you don't say it with kind of an attitude, but you say it very like I'm interested like
How did you come to that conclusion really? I really want to know I'm really interested in what you have to say
What this does is this is helps them see that you are actually
Interested in what they have to say that you actually want to know what they think rather than just give them what you think
And there's a big difference between the two and again
That's why you know last week and this week are connected together because by doing this kind of thing
You're showing them love you're showing them
Relationships you're showing that you care about them as a person not just feeding them your opinion
the most valuable tool
That you or your students have is the ability to sit down
Face-to-face with somebody they have a conversation
There's a lot of tips and tricks to share in your face
But the number one thing to keep in your toolbox is the ability to ask great questions and engage in deep
Meaningful conversations with another person it does so much more than just give the gospel it builds
Relationship so that it I'll say when that person finally receives Christ
that
That discipleship can actually begin rather than just a conversion